[Música]
hablamos de las nuevas medidas
restrictivas contra el cob y 19 en
europa debido al rebrote de esta
enfermedad
confinamientos para los no vacunados
toques de queda y además del cierre de
la hostelería las cifras de contagios y
también de ocupación de la susi obligan
a dar marcha atrás a quienes se creían
haber alcanzado la nueva normalidad
países bajos anunció nuevas medidas y
austria quiere evitar que los no
inmunizados salgan a la calle salvo para
lo más necesario la organización mundial
de la salud advirtió que europa acumula
en estos momentos la mitad de los casos
de kobe 19 del mundo y que sólo la
semana pasada sumó 2 millones una cifra
no registrada hasta ahora para ello
quiero saludar a maría villar ella es la
profesora de sociología de la
universidad nacional de educación a
distancia de madrid gracias a mariah por
estar con nosotros aquí en directo
américa de france 24 pregunta entonces
cómo afecta esto a la sociedad volver al
confinamiento
bueno pues si volvemos bueno en primer
lugar muchas gracias por tenerme aquí
pues sí si volvemos a las restricciones
y al confinamiento lo que podemos
esperar es sin duda un empeoramiento de
la salud mental y de la fatiga que ya
está padeciendo en la actualidad la
población desde el confinamiento los
confinamientos que se produjeron en la
primavera de 2020 y las sucesivas
restricciones que ha habido durante el
último año y medio lo que se ha notado
es que la salud mental ha empeorado en
todos los indicadores ha aumentado en
los índices de suicidios los intentos de
suicidios el consumo de antidepresivos
de de
pastillas para dormir de modo que
esto va a empeorar se puede esperar
cancelar pero además se puede esperar
que vaya a empeorar la fatiga de la
población respecto a las restricciones y
sabemos por estudios que se han hecho en
diversos países europeos que la fatiga
que causan las restricciones
disminuye la confianza de la población
en las autoridades sanitarias aunque
quizás a corto plazo se consiga un
aumento en el número de vacunados pero a
largo plazo puede tener consecuencias
negativas ahora le quería preguntar
marías y entonces esta puede ser una
medida extrema a enviar al confinamiento
a las personas que no están vacunados o
realmente si es necesario también
contando con que estamos en medio de una
situación de crisis sanitaria pública
y yo creo que está este tipo de medidas
tiene
implicaciones éticas
y legales cuestionables y también en
cuanto a la gestión de la
emergencia sanitaria es cuestionable que
su que sea positivo a largo plazo por
este proceso que comentaba ahora mismo
de
empeoramiento de la confianza en las
instituciones también varía alemania
llamó a esa nueva ola como pandemia de
los no vacunados este calificativo
entonces le preguntó si no termina en
una estigmatización para la gente que no
planea recibir esta vacuna y además le
pregunto por qué la reticencia a la
vacuna que ya se ha demostrado
científicamente que realmente evita en
un gran porcentaje las muertes por kobe
19 y desarrollar un kobe 19 grave
efectivamente este tipo de medidas
conduce a unas termitas esta
estigmatización de una parte de la
sociedad
y aún ya el langa agrandamiento de un
conflicto interno dentro de la sociedad
se ha detectado también en varios países
europeos como la confianza de la
sociedad en la propia sociedad se ha
visto mermada durante los últimos meses
de modo que este tipo de medidas puede
contribuir a
perjudicar aún más la paz social no
culpabilizando a un grupo concreto de la
población porque la reticencia a las
vacunas bueno pues puede haber muchas
causas hay mucha gente que no se quiere
vacunar que en realidad no son anti
vacunas que se han vacunado a otras
cosas pero tienen una desconfianza
concreta con estas vacunas también
tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
actitud de los poderes públicos no ha
contribuido a fomentar la confianza en
las vacunas
porque la unión europea sobre todo
durante los primeros meses de las
vacunas hubo muchos cambios legales
sobre qué tipo de población tenía que
vacunarse con cada vacuna y de alguna
forma se fomentó la desconfianza en las
vacunas desde las propias instituciones
entonces ahora se culpabiliza una parte
de la población cuando ellos han tenido
también una parte de responsabilidad en
esto ahora maría también está llegando
la navidad ya a nuestro mundo también
tomó el ejemplo de alemania porque
digamos que es uno de los países que más
fuerte ya a este movimiento anti vacunas
y que más ha tratado de llevar a su
población a vacunarse y también tiene un
alto número de población no inmunizada
ellos ya cancelaron el gobierno alemán
canceló el mercado de navidad de múnich
esto es socialmente como afecta que otro
año sí y otro año más nos cancelen
nuestras tradiciones de navidad nos
reduzcan pues obviamente compartir en
familia nuestras tradiciones ya llevamos
muchísimo tiempo y socialmente como
afecta a más la navidad que es un tiempo
también de reencuentro familiar
pues a medida que va pasando el tiempo y
que se prolonga se prolongan las
restricciones pues efectivamente podemos
esperar que la fatiga de la población
aumente y llega un momento en que ya
dejen de aceptar estas restricciones
está por ver hasta cuándo hasta cuánto
se va a aceptar de hecho yo creo que si
a cualquiera nos hubieran preguntado en
febrero de 2020 si creíamos que la
población iba a aceptar un confinamiento
tan largo como los comportamientos con
europa o restricciones durante tanto
tiempo hubiéramos dicho que no así que
están por ver cuánto puede aceptarla la
población europea estas restricciones
pero
podemos pensar que que habrá un límite
en algún momento varía hacia dónde vamos
que tanto nos ha cambiado este de kobe
19 a nosotros como sociedad
bueno yo creo que nos ha cambiado
bastante está por ver si los cambios son
temporales o permanentes pero
efectivamente el cobista introducido en
la sociedad pues un aumento de ciertas
tensiones sociales una disminución de la
confianza en la propia sociedad la
disminución también de la confianza en
muchos gobiernos
y el índices muy altos de empeoramiento
de la salud mental también de los
problemas personales cada vez más gente
declara que tiene problemas personales
de modo que efectivamente las
consecuencias negativas han sido muchas
por no hablar de las consecuencias
negativas que tiene que tienen las
crisis económicas el desempleo